l'hélicoptère de l'organisateur de la
course thierry sabine
c'était clair et écraser pardon hier
soir au mali vers 19 heures l'annoncé
brutale le 14 janvier 1986 il ya tout
juste trente cinq ans le rallye dakar
est en deuil cinq personnes meurent dans
le crash d'un hélicoptère
parmi les victimes l'organisateur de la
course thierry sabine et le chanteur
daniel balavoine alors au sommet de sa
popularité
l'accident se déroule de nuit dans de
mauvaises conditions climatiques
d'hélicoptères s'est d'abord posé une
fois et puis il a redécollé en suivant
un peu les phares d'une voiture
seulement bon mais ils ont pas vu qu'à
un certain moment la voiture monte alors
qu'yves une dune de 30 mètres la
première depuis 150 km et l'hélicoptère
s'est crashé l'artiste survolé le dakar
à des fins humanitaires notamment pour
installer des pompes à eau dans le
désert balavoine avait demandé à north
panther de ne pas lui faire de promotion
sur cette initiative mais d'en parler
simplement afin que cela soit utile chez
les participants du paris dakar
l'émotion est forte certains sont en
larmes en témoigne la motarde nicole
basso sous le choc est dévastée par le
drame
malgré la tragédie
la course continue en france à des
milliers de kilomètres de là personne
est au courant de la mort de balavoine
son décès n'est annoncée que le
lendemain du drame michel berger l'ami
intime de balavoine a appris la mort du
chanteur seulement quelques minutes
avant d'animer une émission de radio et
on dit toujours que j'arrive pas à y
croire mais c'est vrai c'est parce que
c'est quelqu'un de qui était très très
combatif et qui était l'image même de la
pêche et de la combativité
l'émotion est aussi palpable chez les
français une chapelle ardente est
dressée en banlieue parisienne
des anonymes de tout âge viennent s'y
recueillir en hommage au chanteur
disparu
daniel était quelqu'un qui faisait
partie de de notre vie de tous les jours
quand même non auto si bien que si
demain un sardou hallyday pts 10 passes
et sa part et je crois daniel balavoine
est inhumé à biarritz il avait 33 ans
au total l'artiste a vendu plus de 20
millions de disques dans le monde
[Musique]